what is the millennium and part two is what is its
relationship to the first and second resurrections
the word millennium means a thousand years it's
made up of two uh latin words nearly meaning
thousand and a minute a year so it's a thousand
years the word millennium does not actually occur
in the bible but the expression a thousand years
occurs six times in revelation chapter 20 from
verse two down to about verse seven and so it
is a teaching of the bible and it is a period
of time that comes between the second coming of
christ and the third coming of christ christ comes
the second time according to 2nd peter chapter 3
verse 10 first thessalonians 4 16 he comes back
at that time his brightness destroys the wicked
and he takes his redeemed with him away to heaven
and they're with him for 1 000 years actually we
can go to revelation 20 and begin reading from
verse 1 so that the bible can do more talking
than i do revelation 20 reading from verse 1.
and i saw an angel come down from heaven
having the key of the bottomless pit
and a great chain in his hand and he laid hold
upon the dragon that's all serpent which is called
the devil and satan and bound him a thousand
years and cast him into the bottomless pit
and shut him up and set a seal upon him that
he should deceive nations no more till the
thousand years should be fulfilled and after that
he must be loosed a little season or small season
and so we have the introduction of the thousand
years it is connected with the period when satan
he's chained not in literal chains of course
their change of circumstances because all the
wicked are dead and the righteous are gone and
he's restricted this earth and so the earth is
called the bottomless pit it is not actually
a pit it's just the world in a very very
dilapidated state because at the coming of christ
cities crumble mountains fall islands disappear
jeremiah was given a view of the world in this
chaotic state in jeremiah chapter 4 from verse
23 to 26 i beheld the earth and law it was without
formal void he is describing the condition of the
earth when jesus comes and he takes his language
from genesis 1 1 the condition of the raw matter
before god formed it into something beautiful
and artistic and so he tells us in jeremiah 4
23 i beheld the earth and lo it was without form
and the heavens and they had no light i beheld the
mountains and lo they trembled and all the hills
moved lightly and so the mountains were shaking
literally shaking hills would would overthrow i
beheld and lord there was no man and all the birds
of the heaven were fled nothing was alive that's
that's the state and this is where satan is bound
with his evil angels for 1 000 years and so this
is the millennium and of course while the devil
is on the earth the saints in heaven are doing
something with christ i will get to that i'm sure
based on subsequent questions but the millennium
is a thousand year period which stretches between
the second coming and the third coming amen
amen thank you for that that elder skeet and i
really love how you made it clear that during
the millennium nobody is actually no human
being is roaming the earth the righteous are in
heaven and the wicked dead are in their graves
and we see as well that that millennium is what
separates the first and the second resurrections
if you read verse verse four tells us and verse 5
but the rest of the dead lived not again until the
thousand years were expired or finished and
so we know the rest of the dead meaning the
wicked whom god did not take with them they don't
live again until the thousand years are over when
christ raises them to let them see what they're
about to get and how just the punishment is
what a sight then holy see that
hath part in the first resurrection
on such a second death have no power which means
the second death hath power of those who come up
in the second resurrection which
is at the end of the thousand years
amen amen you know what so you know as you're
talking i'm thinking about jesus how he has
power over life and death and those that are
raised in the first resurrection get a taste
of that same power so if you want to really have
the power of the lord now is the time to commit
our hearts and lives because we do not want
to be in that second resurrection that's right
you